bienvenidos a pizzas soy stone the rose
uno de los científicos informáticos que
trabajan en estas películas atrás de mí
se encuentra en mark andrews el director
de valiente
justo en verte hoy estamos hablando
sobre algunas de las formas en las que
se usan las matemáticas para crear el
bosque en valiente me preguntaba cómo es
para el director trabajar con el
personal técnico
o me encanta todo lo que ves en la
pantalla en una película de pixar no
podría ser así sin el personal técnico
nuestras películas son muy complejas
por ejemplo en valiente lo orgánico que
hay el pasto el bosque el cabello quiero
decir todo es lo que lo hace atractivo y
requiere intensos cálculos en las
computadoras nosotros dependemos
completamente en las matemáticas para
hacer estas películas eso me llena el
corazón de nada gracias así que vamos a
hablar un poco sobre esa complejidad en
el resto de la lección en el vídeo
anterior vimos cómo se usan las
parábolas para modelar el pasto en
valiente una parábola completa es en
realidad una curva infinita pero
nosotros sólo queremos una pequeña parte
a eso se le conoce como arco parabólico
y para crear pasto realista necesitamos
crear otros atributos como varias
lanchas de la hoja su color y cómo se
mueve en respuesta a cosas como los
caballos y el viento veremos todo eso
más tarde en la lección pero por ahora
enfoquémonos en la forma
vamos adentro les mostraré más
entonces la pregunta es cómo vamos a
representar arcos parabólicos de una
forma que los artistas puedan usar pero
también las computadoras tal vez los han
visto por ejemplo como gráficas de
funciones cuadráticas el problema con
las funciones cuadráticas es que no son
muy fáciles para los artistas la mejor
forma es usar tres puntos les mostraré
ok aquí tengo tres puntos y conforme los
nuevos la parábola se ajusta en gráficos
por computadora estos tres puntos se
conocen como polígonos de control
entonces si solo tengo tres puntos de
alguna manera tengo que recuperar el
arco parabólico así que la pregunta es
cómo pasó de estos tres puntos a
recuperar mi parábola y la idea es muy
simple lo primero que haremos es colocar
algunos puntos igualmente separados el
mismo número en cada segmento y lo
siguiente que haremos es empezar a
conectar los puntos conforme conecte
estos puntos empezaremos a ver cómo
aparece la curva
y por arte de magia y ustedes pueden
hacer la misma construcción en la vida
real se conoce como escultura con hilo
observa podemos tomar un pedazo de papel
dibujar algunas líneas y poner más
puntos con la misma separación y luego
con la aguja e hilo podemos empezar a
hacer estas conexiones justo como lo he
hecho aquí a esto le llamamos escultura
con hilo para la construcción de arcos
parabólicos en el siguiente ejercicio
tendrán la oportunidad de conectar los
puntos por su cuenta